um
be good on sound and yeah great okay so
um good where did we leave off I'm gonna
assume that basically everyone
um here and on the video has already
watched um the the last session
but so what we're thinking about is this
algorithm for learning multi-calibrated
predictors okay and we'll go through it
again
um one thing that came up in the break
is that I'm I'm talking about
initializing let's go back to the
highest level version
talking about initializing this
predictor P naught to be a trivial
predictor uh I need not do that the I
can also think about pre-training a
predictor bringing that in and even
incorporating uh sort of level sets from
that predictor into my collection okay
this might be a good way to
um build up on existing techniques so
really this this boosting strategy could
similarly be thought of as a
post-processing procedure to turn your
favorite pre-trained model into a
multi-calibrated predictor okay so
really I can handle any arbitrary
predictor here good
uh it came up that we need to think
about how to check these constraints and
see if they're violated both uh
computationally and statistically
um I promise you we will get to that
um and good and we're thinking about
this update and why it makes progress
okay
um here's the more technical version
again
um
there there is the the truth is that
whenever you're working with predictors
and you need to reason about the
predictions that the predictors are
making
there's some circularity there's some
complication both statistically and just
sort of representationally how do you
represent these predictors
um
there's a lot of technical details
um that or formalisms that you can use
to handle it
um the easiest way is just to round your
predictions to the nearest interval and
uh you need to round them to roughly one
over Alpha buckets if you want to work
with Alpha
um error okay so that's what we'll think
about here
um consequently then
uh this condition requires us to reason
about slightly smaller errors and that
will show up in the time and statistical
complexity
okay
um
and I I promise you we can make all of
these details very formal
um I think for the sake of this talk
that's about the level I want to get
into it okay
um good so so we did say though that
um if this algorithm mcboost uh returns
something if it returns a predictor and
basically just by the termination
Condition it's guaranteed to be
multi-calibrated
okay the question we need to ask then is
when does this predictor terminate
do you argue this we're going to show a
straightforward but important Lemma that
uh the boosting algorithm can run for no
more than let's say poly and one over
Alpha iterations
um from from this Lemma we get an
immediate corollary which is abound on
the complexity of the predictor that
we're going to Output in the end
okay in particular
uh it's not hard to see that the
predictor P tilde Vex is eventually
computed just by uh sort of the
iterative summation of our updates so we
started with a half could be P naught
here
um and then we're nudging our
predictions by some Ada by uh or C's
that we identified times this indicator
of uh your the prediction at the teeth
predictor okay uh this indicator where
we're leveraging PT I leave it as an
exercise to the audience but it's
actually a bit subtle to figure out how
to implement this without getting say a
quadratic blow up in the complex
you just need to do some rewiring tricks
but the the upshot is that our
complexity is roughly linear in the
complexity of our underlying predictors
this uh the sorry underlying
subpopulations okay so if the complexity
is K
to implement a function in C then our
the complexity of the predictor is
bounded by roughly
T times K where T is the number of
iterations and we bound it polynomial in
Alpha yes
the complexity here you're referring to
something like threshold circuit
complexity yeah sure
I'm not going to be too formal here
um I'm in fact just like Matilda is not
hiding uh log factors it's just hiding
like implementation details like
if you work with a very concrete circuit
class then yeah you need to be able to
implement these equality checks or or
threshold checks
um
so for a sufficiently rich computational
model it's roughly and
underlying complexity of C
ities
that's that doesn't depend on anything
it really just depends on Alpha or
anything
exclusive vulnerability
because here it's going to be the one
over Alpha to the fourth yep
great so we'll go through
um and no like like nothing says no
dependence on C okay why why why should
this be true okay it's gonna go by a
very standard potential argument
um familiar to people if you've seen
gradient descent or
um multiplicative weights these kinds of
uh algorithms where we're going to
Define some uh potential function okay
in this case it will be the expected
squared error of your predictor
okay
um because it's a squared error uh it is
non-negative right you can't have a
negative value here which means that no
matter where we start from
if we uh remove potential eventually
we're going to hit zero and we can't go
further than that yeah
negative right right yes
it can be negative and we'll talk about
what
um that's a great catch
um good so this this potential function
is non-negative it starts uh at
um good the other fact we need is like
what's the maximum value this could be
well you know it's it's maximum value is
a constant
okay because it's an expectation of
zeros and ones
um okay and so then the the goal
to argue why this potential argument why
we can't run for too many iterations is
to show that at every update
we make significant progress in this
potential okay the the potential drops
by a poly and Alpha Factor
everybody clear that if if we manage to
show this then we've proofed The Dilemma
okay so how does it go well uh you know
there's going to be some just arithmetic
here but I'm going to expand out the
definition of PT Plus One
okay uh uh over here is my updated
predictor
um and I'm taking the squared error I'm
going to expand that out in order to
pull out this y minus PT term squared
which just gives me uh the potential uh
from before to cancel that out okay and
I'm left with uh
uh two other terms
the first term is exactly this uh
condition on which we're basing our
update
okay
[Music]
um
it's
from the update condition in the
algorithm this value is at least Alpha
squared
okay and uh from
just bounds on these values by the
boundedness of of uh C then this value
is less than or equal to one
okay so in in sum
we're going to be able to balance terms
choosing our Ada appropriately to
account for the sign and uh choosing it
of magnitude so that
uh
difference here is at least let's say
Alpha to the four
I don't I don't mean for you to get
every last detail on this Slide the
first time we go through it at that pace
but it's just to say that like
it's not a complicated argument you're
just expanding squares you're canceling
terms you're and then you're looking at
the fact that
we have a bound from the update
condition
okay and that bound the fact that you're
only updating when you find a
significant violation is what gives you
significant progress in this potential
what it says too uh as a as sort of a
sort of
corollary or intellectual just thought
is that actually these updates are
moving you closer
these updates are are improving your
squared error at every update we're
improving our overall Square there
and that's it okay so uh
uh yeah good so so we have a bound on
the number of iterations that we'll ever
make and this bounds our complexity
um and now
uh the thing that we need to turn to is
checking these multi-calibrations
because they're a question
what how how what was the question about
how to define it is it possible to
Define it differently as exponential
over T so that you can get faster
convergence
uh I'm not sure yeah
I don't know you so so I'm doing this uh
additive nudging update you certainly
can also implement this with them all
complicated
um
why it does not depend on the
compression of C I think basically
because you find that CTF tree
this is the number of iterations
but I'll I I do need to talk about how
we check these constraints but but I
only need so I'm saying how many times
do we need to check the constraints
effectively okay but it's just a number
of iterations that we need to find that
c so that actually
that's right yeah so so this balance is
on the iteration complexity of the
algorithm so how to find that c uh but
you don't ever need to consider
yeah I'm about to talk about that yes
good
yeah I guess the way it feels like it
does depend on C like let's imagine that
CR all individuals
right then essentially like if my Alpha
is set even only too high I'll make no
updates at all because I don't have
enough weight in any individual to make
an update and then as soon as the output
is low enough then I'll make updates on
every individuals
right and so in some sense Alpha is
implicitly dependent on how big my
c-classes are certainly there there are
reasons to set Alpha and according to it
say the size of the subsets that you
want to okay but uh but once we fix
Alpha then for any c this algorithm uh
runs his polynomial and one over Alpha
iterations
oh I mean I'm determinating the
certainly depends on C is because the
potential function uh if C is very like
not complex the potential function won't
have time to go to zero like being
multi-calibrated is not the same as
having potential to be zero uh so you'll
run much less than Alpha to the forward
iterations so in that's like the upper
bound does not occur yeah no I totally
agree uh it's so it's a good direction
in which a dependency is right sure
right uh I think these are all true
statements
um
I think the point is just that there is
an explicit upper bound independent of C
good so okay so the the final thing in
in putting this algorithm together then
is to ask how do we check these
constraints
okay
basically do we know that algorithm will
return the good hypothesis at the end or
something like that or
I don't know what do you mean good the
flu have a good prediction or so it will
be not to calibrate it and we'll talk
about uh whether that's a good thing or
basic squared error the square air
should go now so squared error should go
down like uh yeah all great questions
wait for predictions talk wait for 10
minutes
okay so how do we audit the the key
Insight here is that we can reduce this
auditing problem auditing for
multi-calibration to a certain standard
machine learning problem okay this is
the so-called weak agnostic learning
problem okay where we're given data I'm
labeling it by Z Now
um just to indicate that it could be
something as a function of y a function
of your current predictions and we're
saying that if there exists some C in
our class such that
there's significant correlation with the
Z labels okay there's correlation at
least Alpha
then you need to return me uh uh a
hypothesis that let's say gets at least
polynomial in Alpha
correlation
it's a correlation detection problem and
it's a promise problem that if there's a
significant violation find me something
with uh slightly less significant
violation
okay and and really truly this this
problem is is computationally equivalent
to the auditing problem that if I make
no assumptions about Z then I can plug
in my labels from uh
I can plug in y minus PT as my Z
okay and so so so what this says is that
really this auditing leverages
um exactly the same Primitives that we
would use for some sort of boosting
algorithm right this weak learning is is
thought thought about in the context of
boosting a lot okay and and so the the
upshot of that is that the sample
complexity
um right where where have I touched the
data before the only place I touch the
data is in checking these constraints
right evaluating this expectation okay
and so the sample complexity needed for
this week agnostic learning problem
scales with the VC dimension of C
logarithmic in the class C if it's
finite and polynomial
foreign yeah so we can we it can be a
turing reduction
or we'll we'll think about uh each level
set separately
and and run let's say one over Alpha
iterations of the weak agnostic learning
based on just the conditional
distribution
good
um so so here here's the summer here
here's here's uh sort of what we talked
about
so the final theorem that we get is the
following picks an identifiable
collection C what do I mean by this I
want it to be computable in complexity
uh of say s some concrete complexity and
I want it to be auditable in the sense
that there's a weak agnostic learner for
the class C
okay if those things are true then there
exists a learning algorithm namely this
multi-calibration boosting that makes
polynomial in one over Alpha uh calls to
this weak agnostic learner and in the
end returns to you A C Alpha
multi-calibrated predictor of complexity
scaling at uh roughly as c times the
polynomial again in one over Alpha
um
I mean you can just directly give me
seal just think it sees a bunch of trust
yeah I'm just going to learn P star yeah
and it seems that being color created is
basically the same as uh you know up to
maybe some extent developer is learning
uh is the respect learning P star
so so
um what will show in a second
um is that for a certain versions of
Pac-Man let's say lost minimization
um you can
um what we'll show is that
multi-calibration
and other variants imply loss
minimization imply some sort of pack
guarantee
um and and no in fact in fact the
guarantees of multi-calibration are
stronger than
to really understand
right
can you go back one slide
um so C is mapping X to Zero one
X to negative one one is what's the
reason for that difference here
um I'm not taking any expect uh I'm not
taking an absolute value here I'm I'm
just sort of saying arbitrarily Z could
be plus minus uh yeah okay all of these
things can be interchanged yeah
so let me push ahead let me push ahead
I'm going to talk about sort of the the
sorry I'm going to switch gears to
thinking about alchemy the same
wishability and in particular I want to
think about comparisons of
multi-calibration and outcome and
distinguishability to more traditional
uh paradigms for learning okay so what
what and sort of really the the thought
behind the outcome in distinguishability
is saying what what is
the point of learning what are our goals
here okay traditionally the goal is
framed as some sort of best fit uh
problem find a best fit predictor to the
data okay this best fit is determined by
some overall performance average over
the population as a whole anything else
like fairness is used as a constraint
that that might uh limit your accuracy
um multi-calibration on the other hand
sort of did away with thinking about
loss minimization did away with thinking
about fitting the function as a whole
and only stated this fairness condition
as its first source of wall
and the question is can we generalize
this approach
okay what we're going to do is sort of
put on our cryptographer hats put on our
uh pseudorandom hats and and
appeal to this idea of computational
indistinguishability here okay
indistinguishability formalizes the idea
that two objects can be meaningfully
different but look the same to bounded
and efficient distinguishers
okay so uh with this sort of Framing and
headspace I can describe to you the high
level idea of outcome and
distinguishability okay outcome
indistinguishability is best described
by the following game
okay so in this game I'm going to
present to you a triple an X
uh P tilde of X and A Y okay an
individual a prediction and an outcome y
okay in addition to this I'm going to
promise you that the outcome is sampled
from one of two worlds
in the first world we're going to sample
uh our outcome according to nature of
the note this is why star being sampled
from P star effects sort of sampled from
the true outcome distribution
conditioned on x
in the second world I'm going to sample
the outcome according to my predictive
model
okay according to this probability that
I've already uh presented to you right
okay now comes your job your job is to
guess which World we're in
the guess whether the outcomes were
sampled according to Nature or according
to the model of nature
intuitively we say that a predictor P
tilde is outcome indistinguishable if
you can't win this game
okay if you can't distinguish whether
the outcome was sampled according to
Nature or the model of nature
okay that's the highest level idea
um and we can formalize this
um in fact we're not just going to rely
on uh you know the esteemed audience
here today to do our distinguishing
we're going to appeal to distinguisher
algorithms okay these algorithms which
I'll denote D or a sorry for the
interchange but they take in also an
individual x a prediction P tilde X and
an outcome Y and intuitively their
output aims to guess whether the
prediction whether the outcome was
sampled from nature or the model of
nature okay
and again rather than just using a
single distinguisher algorithm we're
going to use a collection of
distinguisher algorithms okay so this
gives us a formal definition
so for a collection now of distinguisher
algorithms
of the form that I just had on the last
page we say that a predictor P tilde is
a outcome indistinguishable
if it's behavior on each algorithm in
this class for every D in this
collection a
the behavior on Nature's distribution
and the model of nature is similar
okay here when I'm taking an expectation
or a probability over nature versus the
model the probability here is taking
over X and Y
okay X marginally from the true
Distribution on individual sex
and Y then is is what changes
conditionally sampling y either from
Nature's true distribution or from our
model
any any questions on on this definition
before I complicate it further
yes it doesn't depend on what
distribution nature uses
um
so good so so it does depend on on the
underlying nature distribution here
nature would be distort the fixed
unknown distribution that we've been
working with before okay so uh that's
correct the predictor is uh outcome
indistinguishable with respect to this
distinguisher class on a distribution
on the distribution of X Y pairs
yes
yes uh so Peter
Pita live X can represent yeah is a
representation of a probability
good so
um I'm also going to for a notational
convenience and just sort of point this
uh we've been hinting at this we can
take uh sort of these discrete
distinguishers we can also take real
value distinguishers allow a more
General model uh where we take
expectations now over the distribution
of Nature and the model of nature as
long as these distinguishers have
bounded range
okay
um and so then finally uh we're gonna
need uh to be a bit more precise about
this uh approximation and again we'll
just take the absolute difference
between the expectation and nature and
the model of Nature and think of this
Epsilon as being a small const
okay so this is our final definition of
a Epsilon outcome in distinguishability
okay and so sort of like in the world of
multi-calibration I want to emphasize
that the collection of distinguishers we
use here this collection a really
determines the outcome in
distinguishability guarantee if I take a
to be sort of very weak simple
distinguishers then the guarantee will
be considerably weak but the hope is
that if I design this class of
distinguishers appropriately then I can
get out strong guarantees from
uh the distinguishers from outcome in
this industry
okay and so for kind of the remainder of
this portion of the talk I'm gonna start
to go through outcome
indistinguishability go through and try
to map out some of the things that we
can get from outcome
indistinguishability by choosing our
distinguisher class correctly
okay the first uh thing to think about
whenever you introduce a new model of uh
uh a new model is to compare it to the
old model okay so we're introducing this
outcome in distinguishability as a
framework for learning we should compare
to the the sort of standard model for
learning okay uh I'm going to formalize
this through the idea of loss
minimization okay lost minimization
really is the central Paradigm for
learning uh a best fit predictor where
in this problem we're given a loss
function and the hypothesis class h
and a loss minimizer is any predictor
that achieves loss uh commensurate with
the small smallest loss achievable
within this class each
um and so the question that we should
ask then is how does outcome
indistinguishability relate to loss
minimization
there's going to be a whole talk on this
in the afternoon but I want to just sort
of give you a a preview of of the types
of results we can show there okay that
is to say the outcome
indistinguishability is capable of
guaranteeing loss minimization
okay for any hypothesis a hypothesis
class h
um I can design a distinguisher class
that I'll call a sub h
um where if you achieve a sub H outcome
in distinguishability then your
predictor minimizes the squared loss
over this hypothesis class h
um this is this is uh
an instantiation of a family of theorems
of this form but but let's look at what
these distinguishers are doing okay
again and Define uh I'm going to take
one distinguisher for each hypothesis
okay and what's the distinguisher going
to do it's given an X it's given a
prediction on X and it's given a y and
what it's going to do is compare the
difference in the squared error of Y and
the hypothesis
and Y and the predicted value
okay that's what our distinguishers are
going to do they're going to evaluate
the losses over the hypotheses in h and
over our predictions
um and and what should you observe here
the observation is that these
distinguishers
are uh
make sure I get it right our non
negative or non-negative
only if
detailed as a minimizer
Computing the difference so if these
distinguishers aren't are non-negative
then P tilde is in fact a minimizer okay
so how's the argument going to go the
proof idea and we'll see this kind of
proof come up a number of times is an
indistinguishability argument okay we're
going to try to switch our perspective
from a world we want to reason about the
real world we want to reason about
nature but we're going to leverage
indistinguishability to switch our
perspective to a world where our
outcomes are sampled according to our
model
right and if we can do that then we have
our model in hand and we can reason
about the properties of that much more
explicitly okay
but again okay so the point is that if
we achieve this indistinguishability
then the loss on y star the Nature's
outcomes and our modeled outcomes must
be similar that's sort of what
indistinguishability says and further
then we're going to argue that when uh y
tilde is sampled according to a
Bernoulli of P tilde P tilde is the
minimizer this just follows from uh
prove it in a number of ways
okay so so here here's like the three
line proof
um so what are we going to do we're
going to look at this uh the true loss
of H and the true true loss of P tilde
for some H in our class
this difference is equal to this
distinguisher value that's what how we
defined it
okay by outcome indistinguishability
then we can switch from Nature's world
to
modeled world right that's what Alchemy
distinguishability says you can switch
where our our outcomes are sampled from
nature to a world where outcomes are
sampled according to the model of nature
and then we can write you know again
just by the definition we can expand
this and buy the optimality of P tilde
we know that this is the minimizer in
the in the models World okay so this
value has to be non-negative
okay just rearranging then we see that
uh
our squared error cannot be greater than
any H in the class yeah Russell so Pete
Tilda generally won't be in the class so
couldn't the squared error also be much
smaller or are you arguing that it's
about the same uh that's a great
question
um you know we're not uh requiring
the error to be the same anymore right
you might think of trying to equalize
the uh the error the losses we're not
doing that
um so indeed the the squared error of
people that might be considerably less
than the functions in your hypothesis
I think this is the same question but so
you're saying there's no plus Epsilon
there that's oh no no plus Epsilon is
yeah okay plus if you're losing
epsilence yeah I'm I'm I'm lying in
terms of the approximation yeah so
you'll you know it's plus all of Epsilon
good
okay so what this says is that at least
on the face of it
um outcome indistinguishability is
capable of achieving this kind of lost
minimization
um and
uh come to parikshit's talk for the
whole story
okay the next thing to think about is
sort of I said that outcome in
distinguishability was meant to uh
generalize or or try to capture ideas
from the multi-group fairness world
right from multi-calibration
um and so the question that we're going
to ask is how does outcome in
distinguishability this notion of
pseudorandomness in learning how does
this outcome in distinguishability
notion compare to our multi-group
fairness notion how does it compare to
multi-calibration
okay the the sort of upshot is that
outcome indistinguishability and
multi-calibration are computationally
equivalent okay let's just say that that
really this outcome in
distinguishability this world where
we're sort of guessing which World we're
in
is multi-calibration disguise
um and and the way we show this is we
give explicit reductions from C
multi-calibration from achieving C
multi-calibration to some notion of
outcome and distinguishability and vice
versa okay uh and and really the the
translations once you see them are very
straightforward and um I'll go through
some of them next
any questions on this before
okay so the flavor of the the result
that I'm going to show or claim is that
for any collection C
if we want to achieve C
multi-calibration then instead I can
enforce a certain kind of outcome in
distinguishability okay
over this class of distinguishers that I
call a sub c which are defined as
follows I'm going to have one
distinguisher for every C in my class
and for every V in an appropriate
discretization of my prediction
intervals
okay what what does this distinguisher
going to do well it's going to evaluate
C of x
evaluate whether the prediction is in
the appropriate range and then multiply
by one
in effect what this distinguisher is
doing is it's running some sort of
calibration test over the subpopulations
defined by C
so that that's sort of the the claim the
proof again is a very straightforward
application of indistinguishability
okay so again we have for each C and
each V we have a distinguisher
um and we'll write it out explicitly
this quantity here this by definition by
construction is equal to our
distinguisher what does that mean we're
going to do on the next
line
yeah yeah switch worlds right
approximately equal to the world in
which the outcomes are sampled according
to the model
okay uh really it's not a trick it's not
you know there's no tricks here
um okay and then from this we can expand
out in terms of this world that we
understand in terms of this modeled
world where now we can write out by
iterated expectations this quantity the
you know C of x times indicator times P
tilde of x
and relate this back what does that mean
it means that the difference here
subtracting out yeah there's some
probabilities that we need to deal with
there's some Alphas that we need to deal
with at converting Alpha steps ones but
really truly you know if you get uh
Epsilon
all right AC Epsilon oi you're going to
get C Alpha multi-calibration for some
appropriate Alpha
is that clear yeah okay uh just to be
clear you're missing that second Epsilon
uh second e expectation on the last
slide
though right right when you said
iterated expectation there's there's no
new one yeah just be clear I think
that's what I mean by here is I'm just
put I'm pushing yeah so there should
just be one more expectation on the next
line yeah uh oh
[Music]
I'm just pushing the expectation over Y
into here and saying that the
expectation of Y tilde is equal to Pizza
yes so it feels like what you're saying
is that traditionally you fix one
hypothesis and so now with outcome and
disability to reach things there's a
whole class of unmanned statistical
tests would pass as that your hypothesis
would pass is it is it more confident or
I guess what I'm saying is that that
um
by taking this perspective of
indistinguished good but defining a
bunch of tests defining a bunch of
distinguishers and trying to fool them
you can get
interesting qualities you can get lost
communication you can get
multi-calibration
and you can even throw these
distinguishers in together
so that this may be a more expressive
form of learning than just fix it as you
said into fixing one standard object
good
I'm going to go through it but the other
direction is a bit more technical but
really is uh just just uh you know it's
a mechanics it's technical but uh it's
not it's not difficult okay where for
any class of distinguisher algorithms a
I can define a collection of sub
populations C sub a
such that
enforcing multi-calibration over this
collection of subpopulations implies
outcome in distinguishability
okay
intuitively what are we going to do I
mean technically what are we going to do
we're going to define a sub population
for each distinguisher
for each level set and now for each bit
of zero or one that y could take
okay and and the sub populations that
we're going to think about are sort of
uh the pre-image of these distinguishers
are sort of saying uh
look at the X's
on which uh
uh D of x v b b equals one
and and uh where B could be zero or one
and so we we basically need two
distinguishers per or two subpopulations
per distinguisher and levels
point is that these calibration tests
over the subpopulations actually in turn
Implement these this
foreign
I don't have time to really get into it
but what I want to hint at is the fact
that the degree of access that we allow
to this predictor really matters did you
have a
he went and then when you've been doing
these two equivalences you could have
expanded you look if you find very close
can you actually I mean is this uh like
if they go back and forth I mean does
that reach this data point or in other
words you know can can
multi calibration for uh for some
classes equivalent to uh outputability
person first yes good
um the question is basically like
it's a computational equipment it's
giving a reduction from one to the other
right when you know if we run this
reduction over and over again will We
Will We converge or will we just build
up more and more complex
distinguishers or sub operations
um
you converge after maybe two to four
you can always like just slightly expand
the class and then reach something which
is equivalent to something that's
correct uh the the
uh where where it will get a little bit
hazy or tricky is what exactly happens
to your approximation Factor like
the see
uh when I get C Alpha if I want C Alpha
multi-calibration then I actually need
to take a Epsilon outcoming
distinguishability because Epsilon
equals to say like Alpha over four so I
lose something in the in in my
approximation with every iteration but
uh but modulo like the classes don't
become more complex classes don't become
more religious that's right that's right
good question
okay good so so the thing that uh to
emphasize here is that the the degree of
access to our predictive model Maps
okay
um in all in sort of uh
how I defined it originally
all the way back I said I just said that
our distinguishers get access to x p to
live X and Y end of story
but really the way that we access P
tilde
matters
okay uh and and sort of there is a
design
uh space to design distinguishers that
use uh P tilde sparingly or use it uh uh
more efficiently I know that's uh that's
a bit vague but uh the the thing that
I'll claim that is less fig is suppose I
don't give you P tilde they don't allow
you access to P tilde then in fact
rather than being equivalent to
multi-calibration these tests are
equivalent to multi multi-accuracy
okay to this weaker version of monkey
calibration that doesn't require
calibration over subpopulations only
requires unbiased myths
okay so so uh and um
I also didn't go through the algorithms
or the sample complexity for
multi-accuracy in this talk but uh the
the truth is that in both
settings or along along basically every
measure multi-accuracy is more efficient
than multi-calibration
um not not significantly not if we're
only caring about polynomial factors but
like it it's more efficient it has to do
with the adaptivity multi-accuracy is
not allowed to condition on
your current predictions
doing this really really makes things
less efficient and so intuitively and
and it's borne out in the equivalence
not allowing yourself to look at your
current predictions gives you a more
efficient but weaker notion of of uh
outcome than distinguisher
um in the other direction allowing
yourself access even more access to your
predictive model is also an interesting
study what we show in this original
paper is that actually you can define a
whole hierarchy of Notions of outcome
and distinguishability if you allow
yourself say Oracle access to this
predictor and you get a concept that in
uh in a sense I can make formal is
provably stronger than multi-calibration
that it requires you know whereas we
said that the circuit complexity of uh
the multi-calibrated models scale
polynomially and one over Alpha
if you allow Oracle access the the
models that you get actually the
complexity scales
with an exponential factor in
and that that is necessary under some
fine grained assumptions
hey so this is the State of Affairs
again the point is that by this
equivalence
this uh we can use the multi-calibration
algorithm to learn how come
indistinguishable
you can you can sort of go through
exactly the same format and
um
uh
rederive an algorithm just for outcome
and distinguishability it works but but
in a sense the point is that uh just off
the shelf by this computational
equivalence you can get a learning
algorithm
for to learn outcome in distinguishable
models simply from multi-calibration
yeah some of this will be in the next
talk but for loss minimization here it's
really a lot of minimization for square
error and for other losses it's not
known uh it is uh is very is it's quite
known yeah uh yeah
for zero yeah so it's a good question
you should uh in over lunch you should
uh give yourself a homework assignment
to work out whether you can get it for
zero one from the format I uh presented
to you and uh you know Google may help
you
archives may help you
um or you can wait till 2 pm
that one
okay good so
um
great so the the final thing I want to
talk about uh in terms of outcoming
distinguishability is this idea of
universal adaptability okay so this is
yet another property that you might
think about
um that I I don't know how to achieve
other than through the oi or
multi-calibration framework okay what
what we thought about in this work is to
sort of start with um the premise that
often we have a very large Rich well
collected data set
um but it's from a specific place it's
from a specific source of data and we
want to transfer insights or apply
insights from this data set across uh
different populations that may differ in
composition than the source data okay
and so rat uh sort of the classic way to
handle this is through a technique
called propensity rewetting where you
sort of say look I have my source data I
know something about what my target
looks like I'm going to re-weight my
source data to look more like my target
data and uh run estimation in this
re-weighted population
okay what if we don't know the targets
up front what if we don't
um yeah what if we want to handle a
bunch of different targets is there some
sort of way that we could learn a
universal format for a predictor or for
an estimator that would give us valid
estimates in these Downstream Target
populations
okay and what we show is that um whether
you call it outcome indistinguishability
or multi-calibration
um for for any
um that that outcome
indistinguishability is capable of
guaranteeing this Universal adaptability
okay
I I'm not going to write the formal
definition of universal adaptability
right now maybe we'll see it uh in
Kristoff's talk I'm not sure
um but uh basically what it says is that
this predictor this imputation estimate
using this predictor P tilde will be
competitive with the target specific
propensity reweighted uh estimate if you
understood what that means great if not
no worries basically it gives you some
sort of shift robustness and it says for
any uh collection of propensity scores
for any collection of shifts
um you can achieve this notion of
universal adaptability and again sort of
the point is that this collection of
distinguishers what's it going to do it
it sort of says for every shift that I
would want to anticipate or that I would
want to handle anticipate it compute
what the propensity reweighting would be
and be indistinguishable even when I run
this
even under that propensity important
shift
and and once you do that basically you
get it uh pretty immediately
using again us the same exact argument
that we laid out before
okay so so
um yeah we're starting to get a sense of
what what we can learn with outcome and
distinguishability the the one thing
that I wanted to say
um
about
our results here is that a certain meta
approach for learning predictors with
formal properties is is emerging from a
number of different Works where where
where the the learning algorithm goes as
follows first
you identify your favorite property okay
maybe that maybe that's that's uh your
zeroth order uh step you find some
property that you like
okay then the next step is to prove that
Nature's model satisfies this property
come up with some proof that that nature
um that if you could learn the Bayes
optimal predictor and you would satisfy
the problem property okay from that
proof now
devise
a set of distinguishers okay mind that
proof look at what you need for that
proof to go through and come up with a
set of tests that if you fooled them
your proof would still go through
okay and then once you have this class
of tests this distinguisher class just
learn an outcome in distinguishable
model with respect to that distinguisher
class
okay
um and and sort of immediately if the
proof can't distinguish between P tilde
and P star and P tilde must satisfy the
property
um and and sort of if you look at a lot
of the results on outcome and
distinguishability
you can recast what's happening there as
as an instance of this meta approach
okay so I think this is this is really
kind of
um an exciting opportunity for you to
plug in your favorite property here
um like come up with new properties that
you might want to learn and and try to
just turn the crank here
um
yeah hopefully hopefully that's
um clear so I I want to wrap up and I'll
just finish with
um
talking about two directions
um for future research that I think are
particularly interesting in the van of
multi-calibration and outcome and
distinguishability okay so for
multi-calibration one one thing that uh
basically all of these I don't want to
say all a lot of these fairness uh
Notions including multi-calibration they
work in the world of sort of uh
supervised learning a fixed individual
outcome distribution
but often the predictions we make
actually have consequences in the real
world right if I'm uh using a prediction
if I get a prediction that says I'm high
risk for heart disease my doctor is
likely going to tell me to do something
take medicine go exercise
and I intervene in a way that may
actually change my risk for heart
disease okay that's a way in which these
predictions actually can influence the
outcomes that we're observing
okay this this um
this framework was formalized uh by many
of the people who were in the audience
um on this so-called performative
prediction setting the predictions we
make can influence the Distribution on
outcomes that we observe so I think a
really interesting open direction is to
try to formalize what it would mean to
develop multi-calibration like fairness
Notions in a world where our predictions
have consequences
in a world where we need to reason not
just about
um sort of what our predictions say but
what outcomes say induce
okay we have some very initial work
um towards this direction at least
towards understanding accuracy in this
setting but fairness is wide open I
think there's a lot of Technical and
conceptual work to be done there
okay uh and finally the the open
Direction with respect to outcome
indistinguishability is really along
these meta uh approach lines right we we
saw the outcome in distinguishability
gives you multi-calibration loss
minimization Universal adaptability
really the question is what else okay
and a lot of these Works sort of we're
building up this compendium of things we
can get from outcome
indistinguishability
um it's it's a it's a
maybe a good way to write a lot of
papers but an inefficient way to uh
understand something I I think the the
real question here is is is there some
unified guiding theory that tell you
know akin to VC Theory or akin to
um proof uh you know sum of squares
proof complexity that tells you you know
look here is a property that I've come
up with write down this property in some
formal system and now immediately turn
the crank and out from this crank would
spit out uh time complexity the
representation complexity and Sample
complexity needed to learn a predictor
with this property
um
via outcome and distinguishable
um I I think that's a you know it's a
it's a
it's a lofty goal but I I don't think
we're so far away from this
um so I'll pause there and happy to take
any questions
not that you're bothered but
no I am just curious
for the last question yeah
why is NPC dancer also huge because I
mean PC is a necessary sufficient for uh
what question what answer you're looking
for that's not too soon
this is right you're you're correct the
the answer I'm looking for is maybe one
step removed right so BC of the
distinguisher class yes
the question is like I write down an
analytical property of a predictor that
I want
some property how do I translate that
efficiently into a distinguisher class
that would guarantee me this property
yeah
foreign
can I write this in a low degree
polynomial proof system that would tell
me that actually I only need
distinguishers of you know degree K
problems
suspected I don't know exactly what what
uh these things mean but I I think
there's something to be done
it wasn't fast enough to look up some of
the papers that you mentioned it might
be in there but I
um
if for the audience
you have settings where you take into
account the data sponsors
and
um
this is a great question so so uh the
question is about sort of sparseness or
density of the populations that we're
we're trying to audit or trying to
understand and everything that I've said
in this talk assumes that you have data
about the population so you care about
and that you have enough data and you
can get valid estimates in these
populations undoubtedly though even if
you have as much data as you want if you
have less from one group than another
then you have higher ends
and so I think his
um I think One Direction in terms of not
one uh Direction not necessarily
thinking about feedback groups but
thinking about how do we operationalize
parents
would be to somehow reason about the
uncertainty in your production in
addition to you
systems
yeah um in calibration oftentimes as you
said having two groups have three or
four groups you get sort of exponential
in the dimension but I don't see that
sort of showing up in the outcome
indistinguishability so is that um do
you have a have you thought about more
than one category where you have
dimensionality problems
um I see conditioning so yeah a little
Epsilon ball in five Dimensions well
it's Epsilon to the fifth yeah
good so we do so there is we do have a
version of outcome indistinguishability
that can generate
um
uh great so this is the type of this is
the type of uh conditioning problem just
more General distributions if you're if
you're yeah specification of what it
means to have a certain prediction is
multi-dimensional and now naturally
you're going to have an exponential
problem
um
it does show up and
I think we have some I that's a good
question I need to think about it for a
moment
um in some models we we give algorithms
but I think they all depend linearly on
say the support size of the distribution
and in terms of the problem sort of the
way the places exponential dependence is
going to show up is in the sample
complex is in partitioning the universe
according to the different predictions
green question
do they say something wrong I think you
should ask dim the question back and see
how do you define calibration in Q
Dimensions
as you say when you condition you're
going to have one over yourself
the starting point is calibration and
maybe there's a map bigger Notions of
calibration might not be promotions
yeah
minutes
[Music]
uh I'm sorry we went to your next slide
um so about
um
um one question is like I mean like you
said one answer is
fix a proof system uh right uh in that
road system right uh
uh by uh whatever property and uh
kind of distinguishes effect whatever
functions are coming or come up in the
proof so uh you're looking for a more
satisfactory answer than this right so
we have a guess what like on selected
this is an answer yeah I I I don't uh
it might be the answer I don't know
I haven't given much thought beyond that
but it's an interesting question
great thanks so much thanks for the
great questions
I'll be back here at 2PM
where you can learn all about